sabemos que la suma de los ángulos
internos de un triángulo es igual a 180
entonces si la medida de este ángulo es
de este b y de este c sabemos que a más
ve más c es igual a 180 pero qué sucede
cuando tenemos polígonos con más de tres
lados qué pasa ahí vamos a ver qué
sucede con un polígono de cuatro lados
así que voy a dibujar aquí un
cuadrilátero un cuadrilátero lo voy a
seguir regular entonces bueno solo para
mostrarte que sea lo que sea que hagamos
aquí aplica a cualquier cuadrilátero
entonces esto es general no no tiene que
cumplir ciertas características como que
tenga ángulos rectos o lados paralelos
no es general ahora cómo podemos pensar
en esto en el cuadrilátero sabemos que
la suma de los ángulos internos para un
triángulo es de 180 entonces por qué no
dividir este este cuadrilátero en dos
triángulos así voy a dibujar esta línea
ya tenemos aquí dos triángulos ahora si
sabemos que la media de este ángulo está
de este es ven y éste mide c sabemos que
a más
es igual a 180 y si llamamos a este
ángulo x a este ya este zeta
sabemos que x + gemma z es igual a 180
entonces si queremos la suma de todos
los ángulos interiores todos los ángulos
interiores serán de maceta serán unos de
ellos cierto entonces tenemos este y
este de maceta y ahora esos son dos
ángulos de este polígono ahora tenemos a
más x bueno más bien este todo ese
ángulo es a más x ajá es todo este
ángulo de aquí a más x y también tenemos
temas de todo este ángulo ese margen
entonces se mantiene y sabemos que
sabemos que a más ve más cm es igual a
180 y sabemos que se está más x más y es
igual a 180 también entonces más 180
y eso es igual a 360 grados entonces
bueno creo que ya tu ves aquí la idea
general solo tenemos que averiguar
cuántos en cuántos triángulos podemos
dividir algún polígono el que sea y
multiplicar la cantidad por 180 ahora
hagamos otro ejemplo después haremos una
versión general de él de todo esto y
veremos en cuántos triángulos podemos
cuántos triángulos pueden caber en algún
polígono el que sea no ahora voy a
dibujar un pentágono un pentágono
irregular parece una casita
y bueno ahí está tenemos aquí entonces
voy a dibujar tres triángulos en este
pentágono ahí quedaría uno y por ende
otra línea está aquí ya tenemos tres
triángulos ahora bien sabemos que cada
uno de los triángulos tendrá que la suma
de sus ángulos internos será de 180 y
también sabemos otra cosa sabemos que la
suma de todos esos ángulos en los
triángulos será la suma de los ángulos
en el pentágono como un todo ahora
claramente este ángulo interno es uno de
los ángulos en el polígono también este
pero cuando tomas la suma de este ángulo
y este entonces su total será uno de los
ángulos internos del polígono también
acá este más este es uno de los ángulos
internos del polígono ahora cuando sumas
este y este y éste también obtiene ese
ángulo interior entonces si tomas la
suma de todos los ángulos interiores lo
que estás haciendo es encontrar la suma
de los ángulos interiores del polígono
en este caso tenemos un triángulo dos
triángulos tres triángulos tres
triángulos por 180 grados es igual a que
a 300 más 240 son
140 grados ahora vamos a generalizar
esto para hacer debemos darnos cuenta
que sólo para obtener nuestros primeros
dos triángulos tuvimos que usar cuatro
lados entonces tuvimos que usar cuatro
de los cinco lados de los cinco lados en
este pentágono aquí tenemos 12
34 ahora cuatro lados te dan dos
triángulos y parece que por cada lado
que incremento obtengo otro triángulo
así que vamos a experimentar un poco con
un hexágono ahora ahora aunque entonces
sólo quiero ver cuántos triángulos puede
puede obtener puedo obtener con el
hexágono entonces aquí yo tengo un
hexágono un hexágono uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis lados y ok puede obtener un
triángulo a partir de estos dos lados
ajá y también obtener otro triángulo a
partir de estos dos lados parece también
que puedo obtener dos triángulos por
estos dos lados restantes entonces aquí
sería un triángulo y después se forma
otro así que tenemos cuatro triángulos
ahora en general parece que parece que
bueno a ver hagamos algo digamos que yo
tengo un polígono de cinco lados
entonces tengo aquí un polígono de cinco
lados y veamos qué pasa para esto voy a
asumir que ya hicimos bueno de hecho ya
hay signos para el caso de cinco lados
cuatro lados cinco lados y seis lados
entonces podemos asumir que ese es mayor
que 4
y supongamos que yo tengo un polígono de
ese lado y quiero saber cuántos
triángulos caben en él sin que sin que
sin que unos estén encima de otros vaya
que quepan perfectamente en el polígono
así que cuántos caben luego voy a
multiplicar ese número de triángulos por
180 para averiguar la suma de los
triángulos internos de ese polígono así
que hagámoslo una vez más cuatro de los
lados nos sirven para formar dos
triángulos entonces yo aquí tengo dos
lados ya que tengo otros dos lados ahora
no voy a poner aquí el resto de los
lados porque son ese lados pueden ser
una infinidad de lados puede ser esto
infinito entonces bueno no lo puedo
dibujar ni me voy a preocupar por eso
ahorita pero puedo dibujar un triángulo
un triángulo formado a partir de estos
dos lados aquí está uno acá está otro
triángulo entonces cuatro lados usados
para dos triángulos y no importa cuántos
lados queden no no importa ya usé cuatro
de sus lados pero después de eso si yo
tengo un polígono medio alocado así como
como que van
así después así así así bueno mejor lo
voy a dibujar un poco algo mejor porque
ok entonces bueno algo así será nuestro
polígono y bueno tal parece que por cada
al lado incrementado obtengo otro
triángulo así que aquí tenemos un
triángulo o otro triángulo otro más y
otro más entonces bueno por ejemplo esta
figura que dibuje es un polígono muy
irregular de de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
lados es correcto 6 7 8
efe 10 entonces es un descargo no
irregular y entonces bueno en este
descargo no cuatro de los lados fueron
usados para dos triángulos dos
triángulos y los restantes por cada por
cada lado incrementado tengo un
triángulo baja entonces 55 triángulos
está bien esto porque si conté bien el
número del lado tengo a ver 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 y 10 y de hecho si entonces que
estoy haciendo mal que estoy haciendo
mal
o ya creo que ya había aquí está aquí
aquí falta otra línea así si ves aquí
falta otra línea entonces forman dos
triángulos de ese de esos dos lados
entonces tengo estos dos triángulos de
los cuatro lados y de los seis lados
restantes obtengo un triángulo por cada
uno entonces 2 más 6 es igual a 8
triángulos en total y podemos pensar en
esto de una manera general los cuatro
lados nos dan dos triángulos entonces lo
voy a escribir aquí 2 bueno no mejor
a número de triángulos es igual a 2 ya
use cuatro lados más de los lados
restantes obtengo un triángulo por cada
uno entonces tengo ese menos 4 y eso nos
da un total entonces número del
triángulo es igual a 2 más
s menos 4 es igual a ese menos 2 si yo
tengo entonces un polígono de ese lado
puedo obtener ese menos dos triángulos
que perfectamente cubren el polígono y
que no se solapan unos con otros lo cual
es bueno lo cual nos dice que si un
polígono de este lados tiene ese menos
dos triángulos entonces la suma de los
ángulos internos parece polígono será de
s menos 2 por ciento ochenta grados lo
cual es un resultado muy fantástico si
por ejemplo alguien te dice ok perfecto
tienes un polígono de 102 lados así que
ese es igual a 102 y tú dices ok
perfecto que yo que entonces el número
de ángulos interiores será de 102 menos
2 eso es cien por ciento ochenta grados
lo cual es igual a 180 con otros dos
ceros entonces serían 18.000 grados
a la suma total de los ángulos
interiores de este polígono de 102 lados